let me broaden it first of all because I
think the biggest problems in which
business is engaged today are our
climate and climate change and and
global poverty and I think business
actually is starting to get engaged in
them I mean in climate change business
has been a source of the problem and and
industrialization has been a source of
the problem I guess industries are part
of industrialization but businesses are
also going to be the source of the
opportunity Peter Schwartz of the global
business network likes to say that
climate change is a really interesting
thing because there's a lot of money to
be made from remediation of the problem
but I think this is this this is a
baseline issue for everything and if
business is not engaged in it as a
solver of the problem business is going
to be engaged in it as as as being told
told what to do so I think I think I
think that's very important I also think
that as business is part of it in this
global adventure of for large businesses
at least you're seeing a lot of really
serious talk about an action about what
used to be the charitable acts of social
of corporate social responsibility
you're actually seeing a lot of
engagement in that a lot of sort of
business intellectual excitement about
the about those possibilities so I think
those are two big issues outside I think
inside the the biggest issues that I
think these issues sort of come and go
right now in the summer of two thousand
eight among businesses in the OECD
nations where there's been a few years
of pretty good times profits are high I
think there's a lot of concern about
sustaining performance are you managing
for the long-term can we
this going or are we going to screw it
up and I think that's a big topic I
think a big topic because there's been a
lot of stuff about innovation which is
partly related to that same question
about keeping things going can we come
up with new ideas can we come up with
can we come up with innovations I'm
starting to see and this depends a lot
on the business in some industries a lot
of trying to figure out what technology
means for my business or the businesses
on which I depend i mean everybody who
has any retail operations you know
obviously ecommerce bricks and clicks
all of that sort of stuff has been for
the last 10 years has been a big
challenge it's anybody in advertising or
media you know watching the emergence of
new media such as this watching
advertising money flow from television
to the internet from magazines to the
internet from inner to to the and seeing
what's happening with that this is this
is utterly transformative of a whole big
section so that dealing with the
technology or they the business model
change of caused by technology is is is
central and related to that there's a
whole lot of conversation like
Christians and talks about business
model innovation gary hamel talks about
management innovation they're similar
you know sigh or they're looking at the
same problem which is this issue of not
just how do I lead or manage better not
just what in strategy but are there ways
how do I actually look at my fundamental
economic model and figure out whether
there are ways of doing it differently
or how do I pout and changing
you